welcome back golfing dining large events
chimera golf in henderson is a wonderful
destination and thank you to cisco for
sponsoring this segment and here to tell
us more is jeff allen he's the director
of food and beverage and their executive
chef juan is here with us as well good
morning good afternoon gentlemen i
should say thank you for having us
before we get into this food that you
brought and what a spread you have let's
talk about the golf course tell me more
about the actual course itself sure an
18 hole championship golf course a lot
of great views from our tee boxes of the
surrounding area in las vegas
framed by the mountains a very playable
golf course for all levels of golfers
do you want to talk about the slice 19
yeah absolutely well yeah because
actually devon won our photographer said
he's got there many times
it's a fantastic course and when you're
done golfing you want to eat some food
slice 19. chef one with some of the food
that you guys offer yeah so i'm excited
to be here thank you for having us we
just changed into a new menu and
everything about this menu
i was
looking to make sure i can get nothing
but the freshest at a funko so
everything that you see here
most of it is cisco acquired through
cisco but real fast here i have a false
salad that resembles the foliage steak
salad cocktail de camaron
uh poke ball
this is our pastrami burger everything
about these burgers awesome no i've been
a couple of club houses and stuff and i
don't see this kind of food this is
five-star restaurant food is what we're
looking at good
anyone can show up right anyone can make
it like this
we're in the uh tuscany neighborhood but
it's a uh open to the public uh
breakfast lunch and dinner
seven a.m to nine p.m every day debbie
can you get a shot on the other on the
counter of that shrimp cocktail i have
not seen shrimp cocktail that big before
that is shrimp on steroids right there
that's unbelievable that is unbelievable
okay now you got your you got the pan
here i feel the warm pan what did you
make for us today so what i did this is
an item that we serve on our taco
tuesday which is extremely popular we
slowly cook the barbacoa traditional
traditionally and we pants here the
barbacoa tacos and accompanied with a
banana salsa homemade guacamole and a
chunky mild salsa
awesomeness on a plate that's a great
way to summer awesomeness and a plate i
wish you guys could smell the studio
right now because the smell and the
aroma of these tacos is just
unbelievable can you please pass me that
plate chef absolutely i gotta give it a
shot do you guys do a trivia night on
tuesday nights too we do drive tonight
correct from 5 to 8 pm is actually taco
tuesday and inside of that is 7 8 is the
trivia which is very popular so you have
to get there early for that we fill up
pretty quick from that now also too the
holidays are coming up if someone's
watching and they want to have a company
party there how many people can you guys
accommodate we accommodate up to 175 in
our pavilion
we can do we do a lot of weddings we do
banquets all type of events and holiday
parties as you mentioned that is awesome
gentlemen thank you so much for joining
us i gotta give it a bite here hold on a
second
oh my gosh
chef try the sauce let's see how i tried
this sauce i got to go to break but i'll
try the salsa right this is you guys
seriously this is insane well thank you
so much we appreciate j.c thank you to
cisco for sponsoring this event you guys
are fantastic chimera golf club is
located in henderson call them at
702-951-1500 this is so good find them
online at chimeragolfclub.com
rocky over to you you're right over
there